le télétravail est devenu le quotidien
de nombreux canadiens en raison de la
pandémie
mais si cette tendance gagne en
popularité auprès des employeurs tous
niveaux pas là une recette miracle
et c'est le cas d'ailleurs de christiane
germain qui est coprésidente de germain
hôtel qu'une position pour était très
nuancée sur le télétravail
elle est avec nous pour en discuter
bonjour madame germain bonjour le cybook
alors évidemment il ya eu la nécessité
du télétravail durant la pandémie
mais lorsque la situation va revenir à
la normale vous n'êtes pas convaincu que
c'est la merde solution là pour les
entreprises
en fait vous l'avez dit je pense que
j'ai effectivement je suis pas convaincu
j'ai une position nuancée et je pense
que on doit en parler on doit c'est pas
juste c'est pas noir et c'est pas blanc
je pense que c'est important de deux
d'en parler ouvertement
c'est quoi votre position justement sur
le télétravail va écouter dans
l'hôtellerie vous comprendrez qu'il ya
des postes même pas question que les
travailleurs qui sont en lien direct
avec la clientèle parce que je pense que
si c'est on n'aborde pas la question
mais il ya toujours ce qu'on appelle
back up down qui où il ya des postes qui
sont dans les bureaux et je voudrais que
j'élargis un petit peu mon mais mon
champ d'activité parce que je sais
quelque chose que j'ai eu l'occasion de
parler avec d'autres et je pense que il
ya des postes dans les entreprises qui
se prête bien au télétravail mais même
si ça secret bien il ya des conséquences
importantes au télétravail que jean de
concession selon pas ce concile humains
sont indissociables la côte obligeant
également peut-être je pense que c'est
important côtoyer des gens je pense que
quand on parle d'innovation c'est
important d'être en contact avec les
gens quand on parle de de sentiment
d'appartenance à l'entreprise quand on
parle de culture d'entreprise
ces choses-là se transmettent beaucoup
mieux et beaucoup plus facilement quand
on est en contact avec les gens alors
moi je c'est sûr que si vous m'aviez
posé la question le 1er mars de cette
année probable
il est probablement mais le télétravail
ce n'est pas une option c'est devenu
maintenant une option mais pas sur une
base continue
je pense qu'il faut qu'il faut les
employer faut qu'il faut qu'ils
communiquent entre eux et ça a été une
sainte et extraordinaire ça nous a aidés
à passer à travers cette cette crise là
le télétravail avec les nouvelles avec
les petites technologiques sont
disponibles que je pense qu'on doit pour
faire attention à prendre des décisions
importantes par rapport au télétravail
souhaite à l'expérience qu'on a vécu en
france lé télétravail peut même nuire au
développement parce que vous n'avez
parlé de la culture d'entreprise alors
l'éloignement ça provoque en quelque
sorte de détachement
ça provoque le détachement qui vous
parlez de développement développement
des affaires c'est difficile de faire
des du développement des affaires avec
une des plateformes
peu importe laquelle un moment donné
vous faut rencontrer des gens faut
passer du temps pour établir le contact
et je pense que il y aura un équilibre à
créer dans dans les prochains dans le
futur entre le télétravail et le travail
au bureau est-ce que vous avez beaucoup
d'employés actuellement qui sont en
télétravail
on en a beaucoup actuellement parce que
comme je dis que je veux pas les halles
encore à l'encontre des règles qui nous
sont demandées par la santé publique
alors on suit les règles tout le monde
n'est pas de retour au bureau mais
tranquillement au fur et à mesure que
c'est possible de ramener des gens au
bureau on ramène des gens ont bureau
puis on n'est plus aussi les employés
dans la façon dont on frôle télétravail
c'est pas quelque chose que je veux
imposer comme employeur mais je veux en
discuter et m'assurer que la culture de
l'entreprise et est toujours bien
transmises et fait toujours partie des
valeurs importantes de l'entreprise
actuellement on a dit qu'il s'agit d'une
l'une des tendances du marché du travail
est ce que vous pensez que le
télétravail est là pour durer pour
rester longtemps
je pense que oui mais quand je mens
quand je parle de thé l'état de travail
de télétravail pardonnez moi je parle de
créer un équilibre entre ce qui se
faisait avant
et ce qui s'est fait pendant la pandémie
mon opinion est que ce qui s'est fait
pendant la pandémie n'est pas quelque
chose de durable c'est à dire toujours
des taux toujours est à la maison et ne
jamais venir au bureau je ne crois pas
que ce soit une solution durable pour
l'avenir et le développement des
entreprises aussi comme vous le savez on
a une économie à rebâtir et je pense
qu'on va avoir besoin de toutes les
entreprises et tous les gens qui en font
partie
va falloir se serrer les coudes et je
pense que le le équilibre dans le
télétravail a été au bureau ensemble
pour faire ça va être très important
femme brûlée lève aussi lui poser la
question a terminé à cassel germain
comment ça va dans l'hôtellerie à lhassa
a été d confiné on sent que
tranquillement pas vite les clients
reviennent
comment ça se passe à vos hôtels ça va
je vous dirais par secteur ça va très
bien c'est pas une cachette que
charlevoix super bien on est très
contents les centres villes sont très
difficiles marché secondaire ayant sa
bouche un petit peu on sent que les gens
malgré tout ont encore le goût de voir
un petit peu de pays alors mais
charleroi c'est c'est un été fantastique
effectivement on a tendance à beaucoup
de monde à charleroi beaucoup de monde
bas saint laurent gaspésie et c'est que
c'est jamais merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous une position qui est
différente je trouve des autres
entrepreneurs merci merci beaucoup
plaidé en soirée